so you're obviously a kid man are you
like it's summertime
um
what are you are you in school still are
you like what's what's what's going on
like with your life as a kid trying to
make it in the rap game man uh
i don't go to school no more like yeah
it's summertime but i don't go to like
public school no more because like
so like i got a girl like my girlfriend
goes to my school and like whenever like
we would be walking in the hallways
together like people would be hollering
like like like and whenever we would go
to football games like they would say
like weird [ __ ] like oh make out do this
do this do that like just making my girl
feel mad uncomfortable because my girl's
not like really uh she's not used to all
this [ __ ] going on so i just i was like
you know i don't wanna be a distraction
for what you got going on so i'm just
gonna i'm gonna take a step back and
also because like there was a lot of
[ __ ] going around in school so it
was like
people
you know in the rap game people want to
like try to go viral by like testing
somebody so there's people in school
like trying to like do trying to catch a
clout moment yeah yeah yeah and uh like
i would be getting in fights all the
time so like because because people want
to go viral want to want to do this do
that and they think just like just
because i'd be on tick tock and i'm like
up like did like the [ __ ] like
that it's all going to be cool and sweet
that's not that's not what it is so
you're in school
buzzing obviously this cypher moment has
kind of put you on a different level but
in terms of like
you're known as a rapper at school yeah
you're in a relationship at school yeah
and because you're getting so much
attention
it's kind of making your school
experience a little shitty especially
for your girl you're saying yeah i mean
i could sit on here and lie all day and
act like i'm a great student because
i've never really been a great student
and that and that's not like i can't
blame nobody but myself i never really
just i never really saw the value in
school and i may sound ignorant saying
that but it's just putting them bars
together man yeah it's just like i feel
like there's always something like i
feel like there's something
like i feel like i could be taught more
valuable things outside of this
are you gonna finish and get a i'm gonna
get a g i'm gonna get a general
education but if you're gonna get the
ged if i don't get a ged i'm going to do
online and get a diploma because like
i'm still going to get a backup plan
because i'm fully accepted with the fact
that i could i could fall off tomorrow
like yeah this rap [ __ ] is is finicky
man yeah and and longevity is a really
really difficult thing in it so you know
i just it's like
i i understand that you know i'm on this
show today
everyone can forget about me tomorrow so
i'm always accepting and understanding
with the fact that like i can fall off
any day like we've seen it like like
everybody who's like
followed the music industry and like
paid the slightest bit of attention
right we know who's falling off and
who's stayed relevant over the last
couple of years for me